it sounds well and is an excuse but the
bottom line is compete to defend be
aggressive and be the same plan when the
brunch is a bonus to have lebron james
and they say well what's the different
between Lonzo ball and Andre Drummond
well one guy has to shoot it to make us
cool absolutely Kuzma beautiful fake got
Griffin on his feet big block on Reggie
Miller my friend but I remind them
[Music]
Blake Griffin doing a very good job
reading double-teams and making plays
nice play it by him aqui that time and
then Kyle Guzman with a smart play
cutting to the rim I caldwell-pope
couple of possessions ago
here's Kuzma from the corner it's good
back-to-back threes for the Lakers good
offense by the Lakers ronzo ball got the
deflection of the steal and fires to
Ingram collected by kuzmic
cuts it in
Kuzma hesitated gets it backfires away
29 for Kuzma but when teams are
struggling like Detroit you got to find
a way to win these games I heard the
guys on the pregame show talking about
both teams to feel them that can really
heat up and knock down shots Oh get
shooters on the floor and Calderon
Galloway
[Applause]
a new career-high 41 and he's going for
42 a clinic and the fans raining down
coos from the stands here at Staples